This is the National Mall in
Washington, D.C.
More than 25 million people
visit annually. At
lunchtime on any given
day, hungry tourists spill
out onto the streets.
Majeed Naim, the owner of the
food Truck Chicken Friendly, is
feeding them
from his spot in front of the
National Museum of American History
as he competes against dozens of
others in a parking free for all.
Location is everything.
To keep their prized
spots, vendors park dummy
cars overnight.
These trucks offer better value
than the pricey cafes at the
Smithsonian Museums.
Right now, customers are at the
National Mall and they're screaming
out for more food options.
Attorney Justin Pearson directs the
National Street Vending Initiative
at the libertarian legal nonprofit,
the Institute for Justice.
So it makes sense that food trucks
try to provide those food options so
that the food trucks can stay in
business and not lose their dream.
The diversity is incredible.
The food is so well cooked.
You can see they really poured their
hearts into it.
The prices are extraordinary.
You can't beat it.
These food trucks really have an
impact on people around here.
And, you know, I just think they're
good for the community.
They face another challenge.
These guys.
We are like struggling a little bit
with the tickets every day.
Sometimes $200 each day, $300
each day. So it's not like easy
here.
Sometimes the police bother
us. Sometimes.
I mean, not sometimes, all the time
we get that like a ticket.
Selling food from a truck along the
National Mall is technically
illegal.
That mattered less before COVID
because there were other
neighborhoods where they were
allowed to serve lunch.
So what was appealing
was the gratification
you get when you have 50 people
in line that are just going to try
your food and they love it.
The pandemic obviously closed
all of the office buildings.
Trucks then ha d to find other
places to vend.
The mall became the only spot in
D.C. with significant lunchtime
for traffic.
So we walk here and
National Mall for just the tourists.
Before name was serving chicken
fingers. He raised the live chickens
on a farm in Egypt.
He eventually saved enough to buy
his own truck.
We hope everything goes back to like
a normal. I don't have nothing else
to do besides this, only the
foot truck business.
Meanwhile, the fines rack up.
Last year the city collected
$467,000
in parking tickets along with them
all.
What's happening at the National
Mall is a real shame.
Customers are being ripped off by
overpriced food sold
at the museum's cafeterias, and
that problem is directly a result
of the lack of competition.
It's ultimately a problem of
jurisdiction.
Nobody seems to want to be
take charge on the enforcement.
Patrick Rathbone, who's the owner of
the big cheese truck used to serve
the D.C. lunch crowd.
Now he focuses exclusively
on catering and special events.
So the roads, our D.C.
jurisdiction as from the sidewalk on
is National Park Service.
They think the National Park
Service, maybe, should be doing
enforcement. So there's inter-
bureaucracy like apathy,
I guess. Nobody wants to be in
charge of actually taking care of of
the trucks down there.
The National Park Service has
resisted calls from lawmakers to
make vending legal there.
I think there has to be a meeting
between the D.C.
folks and the National Park Service.
DC can say we can solve the
parking in the illegal vending
piece of it, but if we don't solve
the transaction side of things
that's in your hands, Park
Service, it's not going to work.
With no compromise in sight, food
truck operators remain stuck in the
middle.
And millions of visitors keep coming
to the mall every year looking for a
delicious and affordable lunch.
With officers waiting nearby.
I see the future kind of like
a little bit difficult because
we still get like bothered
from park police and
for the tickets.
So I was thinking I would have
to leave this business to get
something else but for now, I'm
still in this business to see what's
going on.